people in Sudan have been spending an
anxious night after fighting between the
Army and the country's biggest
paramilitary group the rapid support
forces the doctors union says at least
27 civilians have been killed
there were explosions and gunfire in the
capital of Khartoum and other parts of
the country on Saturday the Army is
refusing to negotiate with the rapid
support forces posted a video on its
Facebook page reportedly showing
soldiers denying the Takeover of the
Corps of Engineers headquarters in the
city of onderman
Saturday April 15th we are now in the
Armory of the engineer Corps in omdurman
Sudan whoever is saying that the
engineer core has fallen we are now at
the heart of it in front of the Sudanese
flag
well the fighting has been concentrated
in Sudan's capital there were heavy
clashes near the state TV building the
presidential Palace and at the
International Airport
350 kilometers Northwest of Khartoum
there was fighting around an airport in
the city of merui in southern Darfur the
Sudanese Army still controls the airport
in the town of Nyala but violence has
been reported there as well gibber
Morgan reports from cartoon
it doesn't look like the situation is
de-escalating in fact the Army put out a
statement saying that it will not
negotiate with the rapid support forces
until those forces are dissolved and the
rebel uh troops are dealt with so it
looks like uh if despite the fact that
people have been calling for a
de-escalation of the situation here in
the capital across the country the Armed
Forces uh look like they're going ahead
with dissolving the rapid support forces
and continuing to attack they've already
labeled the group as a rebel uh force
and we we're seeing a continuing of
fighting here in the uh in the area of
hartum near the vicinity of the
presidential Palace we can still hear
shots being fired we can hear Heavy
Artillery uh being fired it's not clear
yet who is in control of the
presidential Palace but the Army says it
is in control of the headquarters uh the
state television is being battled over
both sides wanting to gain control and
Khartoum International Airport at the
moment looks to be in under the control
of the Armed Forces so so the escalation
continues a lot of tension here in the
capital as fighting continues between
both sides with civilian Scott in the
middle
heavy fighting spreads through her tomb
as tensions between the Sudanese Army
and the powerful paramilitary force
spill over into the streets
the Army says it's defending itself from
attacks by the rapid support forces
across the capital it is now designating
the force as a rebel group
we the Army did not initiate any fight
we were present in our Command and we
were surprised with the attack at about
9 10 this morning coupled with an
assault on my residence the Army did not
deploy or make any movement the Army
Headquarters and presidential Palace are
under the control of the general command
we do not wish to see this country
slipping into war however we must teach
a lesson to any non-regular militias
but the rapid support forces say their
bases were attacked by the army
this battle will pave the way to a
peaceful solution all those criminals
will stand trials I cannot give a time
limit to the fighting however we are
adamant to end it with the least of
losses
International Airport where armed men
are on the tarmac and Rapid support
forces entered State television service
Sudan TV
this was the moment the station's
broadcast was cut
the fighting hasn't just been confined
to the capital there's been violence in
North and South Darfur West and North
Korean States as well as marawi in
Northern Sudan both sides claim control
of major facilities there and in other
areas but so far it's been hard to
confirm who has the upper hand
tensions between the Army and the rapid
support forces emerged months after a
military Takeover in 2021 and they
heightened when talks to integrate the
rsf into the army stalled
I really feel very sad and very angry
actually I'm enraged and I see I I I say
to both of them share my new both of you
you have been entrusted for this great
Revolution and uh you already committed
an nonsensical coup
in Vietnam U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken said Washington would
continue to support Sudan's transition
to a civilian-led government it's a
fragile situation
there are
other actors that maybe
pushing against that that progress but
this is a real opportunity to finally
carry forward the civilian-led
transition and one that we and in other
countries
are trying to uh to bolster
[Music]
Sudan are bracing themselves for more
fighting a new crisis and an uncertain
future Heber Morgan Al Jazeera cartoon
the Sudanese Army as well as
pro-democracy groups have long demanded
the rapid support forces be integrated
into the military it's estimated the
group consists of about 100
000 Fighters Muhammad Val explains how
it was formed
the rapid support forces are
paramilitary Fighters mainly from Darfur
the rsf was created by a former
president Omar Bashir in 2013 to
stabilize the war-torn region in Western
Sudan and more broadly to consolidate
his personal grip on power
he was concerned about any security
institution being strong enough to
overthrow and challenge him so he
allowed you know he allowed basically a
proliferation of different
um armed groups and centers of power
within the country
but the origin of the force goes back to
2003 that's when President Bashir
created and armored tribal militia to
crush a local rebellion in the west a
force became known as the gender wheat
Sudan's current ruler General Abdel was
instrumental in creating and training
both ajanta weed and later the rsf he
worked in the field for years with his
now deadly arrival Muhammad hamdan taglu
known as Hamati the commander of the rsf
in 2019 the two men joined forces to
overthrow Omar Bashir al-borhan had the
transitional military Council and hadan
Douglas served as his Deputy but the rsf
continued to grow in both sides and
means by some estimates it now boasts
one hundred thousand personnel
it took on several roles including
border security and maintaining Law and
Order across Sudan activists accused rsf
of participating in the killing of 123
prone democracy protesters in June 2019.
but its amity's aspirations for
unrivaled political leadership in
Khartoum that led to Discord with his
Ally al-burhan and paved the way for the
current situation differences over the
terms of integration of the other self
into the army intensified after the
signing of a framework agreement that
laid the foundations for the
transitional period in December 2022 the
failure of talks on this and other
issues finally led to what observers
have been warning about an all-out
military confrontation crisis group was
warning
um uh just 10 years ago uh you know
while Bashir was still in power that if
he ever left power one of the big
concerns would be that he left behind
such a mess in terms of the military
insecurity that a huge risk was that
these parties would themselves turn on
each other as ever it's the civilian
population that pay the price there's a
palpable fear that the current conflict
may prove more deadly and more
destructive than any Sudan has witnessed
in the past Muhammad Val
U let's take a closer look at how
matters evolved the most recent bout of
instability in Sudan began in 2019
that's when the military house did long
time neither um after months of mass
protests then the Army moved against the
protesters but under International
pressure it was forced to sign a power
sharing agreement with civilian groups
elections were set for 2023.
in October 2021 yet another military
takeover unseated prime minister
Abdullah handok who was seen as the face
of the transition to democracy
on December 5th last year military
leaders signed another deal with
political groups promising to pave the
way for fair elections and the return to
civilian rule and two weeks ago Sudan
was set to take the next step by
disputes about how to integrate the
rapid support forces into the army got
in the way
he's a researcher and a policy analyst
based in Khartoum he says some political
groups in Sudan have been aggravating
the situation
for the past few days a lot of islamist
leaders associated with the former
regime of Omer Bashir have been going on
on social media uh suggesting that the
next few days will be very critical you
will see very
you know strong responses to the
continuous exclusion of the islamists
and of the political process that
continues to exclude them and so on so
they have been openly mobilizing their
agents their allies within the military
and other
foreign
Associates through our different groups
to you know continue uh putting fuel in
the fire between between the rapid
support forces and the military so I
would suspect that has had you know a
huge part in uh accelerating the the
escalation between both forces so any
examples support forces are not
independent in any way and are not
operating on their own in any way they
are both an extension for uh Regional
forces and and and and so on and with
the International Community exerting
pleasure on their respective allies of
the of the staff and the other set and
pushing them to to
restore calm and and and and to end the
fighting and go back to talks uh would
would definitely go a long way